[Music]
fashion had been living in changan
deploring the mutilated in perfect state
of the collection of the books of
discipline in the second year of the
period hong-chih he entered into an
engagement with Hawaii King tell Ching
hai yin and hai way that they should go
to India and seek for the disciplinary
rules li hao the prefect of tan wong had
supplied them with the means of crossing
the desert before them in which there
were many evil demons and hot wings
travelers who encounter them perish all
to a man there is not a bird to be seen
in the air above nor an animal on the
ground below though you look all round
most earnestly to find where you can
cross you know not where to make your
choice the only mark and indication
being the dry bones of the Dead left
upon the sand
the travelers went west towards towards
North India and they succeeded in
getting across and through the range of
the onion mountains the snow rests on
them both in winter and summer they're
also among them venomous dragons which
when provoked spit forth poisonous winds
and caused showers of snow and storms of
sand and gravel not one in ten thousand
of those who encounter these dangers
escapes with his life the people of this
country call the range by the name of
the snow mountains when the travelers
had got through them they were in North
India and immediately on entering its
borders found themselves in a small
Kingdom called tolay where also there
were many monks all students the way was
difficult and rugged running along a
bank exceedingly precipitous which rose
up there a hill like wall of rock ten
thousand cubits from the base when one
approached the edge of it his eyes
became unsteady and if he wished to go
forward in the same direction there was
no place on which he could place his
foot and beneath were the waters of the
river called the Indus in former times
men had chiseled paths along the rocks
and distributed the ladders on the face
of them to the number altogether of
seventy at the bottom of which there was
a suspension bridge of ropes by which
the river was crossed its banks being 80
paces apart
from this place they traveled southeast
passing by a succession of very many
monasteries with a multitude of monks
who might be counted by Myriad's after
passing all these places they came to a
country named Martello were there 20
monasteries which might contain 3,000
monks and here the law of Buda was still
more flourishing everywhere from the
sandy desert in all the countries of
India the Kings had been firm believers
of that law the laws and ways according
to which the kings presented their
offerings when Buddha was in the world
have been handed down to the present day
all south from this is named the middle
of the kingdom in it to the cold and
heat are finely tempered and there is
neither hoarfrost nor snow the people
are numerous and happy they do not have
to register to cultivate the royal land
but they have to pay a portion of the
gain from it if they want to go they go
if they want to stay on they stay the
King governs without decapitation or
other corporal punishments criminals are
simply find likely or heavily according
to the circumstances of each case even
in cases of repeated attempts at wicked
rebellion they only have their right
hands cut off the Kings body guards and
attendants all have salaries throughout
the whole country the people do not kill
any living creature nor drink
intoxicating liquor nor eat onions or
garlic the only exception is that of the
Chand Alice this is the name for those
who are held to be wicked men and live
apart from the others when they enter
the gate of a city or marketplace they
strike a piece of wood to make
themselves known so that men know and
avoid them and do not come into contact
with them
in that country they do not keep pigs
and fowls and they do not sell live
cattle in the markets there are no
butchers shops and no dealers an
intoxicating drink in buying and selling
commodities they use calories only the
Chandar Lazar fishermen and hunters and
sell flesh meat after Buddha attained to
Nirvana the kings of the various
countries and the heads of the VCRs
built the horrors for the priests and
endowed them with fields houses gardens
and orchards along with the resident
populations and their cattle the grants
being graved
on plates of metal without one daring to
an album and they remain even to the
present time having crossed to the river
and descended south for a Yojana
the travellers came to the town of
badali Putra in the kingdom of Megara
the city where the king ashoka ruled the
royal palace and halls in the midst of
the city which exists now as of old were
all made by spirits which he employed
and which piled up the stones reared the
walls and gates and executed the elegant
carving and inlaid sculpture work in a
way in which no human hands of this
world could accomplish the cities and
towns of this country are the greatest
of all in the Middle Kingdom the
inhabitants are rich and prosperous and
value with one another in the practice
of benevolence and righteousness every
year on the eighth day of the second
month they celebrate a procession of
images they make a four wheeled car and
on it erect a structure five storeys by
means of bamboos tied together this is
supported by a king post with poles and
Lance's slanting from it and is rather
more than twenty cubits high having the
shape of a taupe white and silk like
cloth of hair is wrapped all around it
which is then painted in various colors
they make figures of divas with gold
silver and lapis lazuli grandly blended
in having silken streamers and canopies
hung out over them there may be twenty
cars all grand and imposing but each one
different from the others
[Music]
all through the night they keep a lamps
burning have skillful music and present
offerings this is the practice in all of
the other kingdoms as well the heads of
the Vice er families established in the
cities houses for dispensing charity and
medicines all the poor and destitute in
the country orphans widowers and the
childless men maimed people in cripples
and all who are diseased go to these
houses and are provided with every kind
of help and doctors examined their
diseases they get food and medicine
which their cases require and are made
to feel at ease and when they are better
they go away of themselves fashi an
abode in this country two years having
obtained his sanskrit works
he took passage in a large merchantman
on board of which there are more than
200 men and to which was attached by a
rope to a smaller vessel as a provision
against damage or injury by the large
one from the perils of the navigation
with a favorable wind they proceeded
eastwards for three days and then they
encountered a great wind the vessel
sprang a leak and the water came in the
merchants wished to go to the smaller
vessel but the men on board it
fearing that too many would come cut the
connecting rope the merchants were
greatly alarmed feeling the risk of
instant death afraid that the vessel
would fill they took their bulky Goods
and threw them into the water rush and
fearing that the merchants would cast
overboard his books and images he could
only think with all his heart I have
traveled far in search of our law let me
buy or dread and supernatural
our return from my wanderings and reach
my resting place
in this way the tempest continued day
and night till on the 13th day the ship
was carried to the side of an island
where on the ebbing of the tide the
place of the leak was discovered and it
was stopped on which the voyage was
resumed on the sea there abouts there
are many pirates to meet with whom is
speedy death the great ocean spreads out
a boundless expanse there is no knowing
east or west only by observing the Sun
Moon and stars was it possible to go
forward in the darkness of the night
only the great waves were to be seen
breaking on one another and emitting a
brightness like that of fire with huge
turtles and other monsters of the deep
all about the merchants were full of
terror not knowing where they were going
the sea was deep and bottomless and
there was no place where they could drop
anchor and stop but when the sky became
clear they could tell east and west and
the ship again went forward in the right
direction if she had come on any hidden
rock they would have been no way of
escape
[Music]
when I look back on what I have gone
through my heart is involuntarily moved
and the perspiration flows forth that I
encountered danger and trout the most
perilous places without thinking of or
sparing myself was because I had a
definite aim and thought nothing but to
do my best in my simplicity and
straightforwardness thus it was that I
exposed my life where death seemed
inevitable if I might accomplish but a
ten thousandth part of what I hoped
[Music]
you
[Music]